IRIQTAQ HAILSTONE: We grew
up following our parents.
My parents always took
us along with them.
So I have that
mentality in my head
that if I can't take
my kid then don't go.
[peaceful music]
CHIP HAILSTONE: He's
a handsome little boy.
So cute.
CHIP HAILSTONE: Wow,
you got green eyes, kid.
My son's name is
Sebastian Orion [inaudible]
[inaudible] Hailstone.
Orion [inaudible]
is Orion the Hunter,
so he's my little hunter.
Yeah, he's totally
got your chin.
It's the baby's name.
Huh, Sebastian.
Sebastian.
I'm the auntie of 13.
So I've had a lot of practice.
Plus I helped grow up
my younger sisters.
Now I have a lot of
help with my own son.
[cold music]
You gonna go ride with your
mom and go snares for rabbit?
I'm going to get
the rabbits for you.
Oh, you're going to
go get rabbit for me?
Yes.
NARRATOR: Mary's daughter Rose
and [inaudible] son Sebastian
are the latest additions to
the growing Hailstone family.
To provide her niece and
nephew with furs to keep warm
through winter,
[inaudible] will head out
to set snares for rabbit pelts.
The task will also
pass on a native skill
to her young son, Wade.
In our culture, usually when
the women have a new baby,
we try and make them
their own outfits.
The best material for
our kind of conditions
are the materials that
are locally resourced.
So we're just trying to get some
rabbit skins together, and sew
a few things for baby Orion.
Oh, look.
You see all the tracks?
Wow.
Yeah we'll get the
Willows first, yeah?
So as we keep going we'll
be able to set traps.
The rabbits are?
Yeah.
Wait, where?
Over [inaudible]
Wade just turned
three years old,
so you could only keep
his attention for so long.
He's a very active child.
Watch out, Mom.
I thought [inaudible]
your head, Mom.
When we find something
he's interested in,
it's entertaining
and fun to watch
him because he's so involved.
There you go.
Some more.
Oh, almost.
I remember being a little
kid and following my dad
out, checking traps and snares.
You know, even though
he's at a young age,
just watching and listening
to you, just being around you,
they pick up and learn a lot.
You explained things the
best you can, and show
him what's safe and what isn't.
OK, wait, I think we
got enough Willows.
[grunts]
You're going to
pile them up for me?
Yeah.
That way they're
learning how to provide
and learning the cycle of
life and how things are done,
and where food comes from.
Thank you.
OK, right there is fine.
You could look in
the backpack and grab
the snare wire, please--
and the tool that's
in there with it.
Here, Mom?
Yup, I need that one.
And where's the tool?
I need the tool too.
This one?
Yup.
Thank you.
Sun's dropping on us?
Yeah.
The sun's trying
to go down on us.
Oh.
I taught my son
something, and it just--
it feels good.
It feels good to be
able to be that active
and be able to do
such things up here,
and teach my son that nothing
is ever too hard if you
just set your mind to it.
We'll come back tomorrow
and check our snares, OK?